the little prince is sitting on his
little planet and he's watching the
planets go by and so suddenly he's
seeing three of them one two three and
he wonders mmm what would the center of
mass of these three planets be so let's
calculate it we have one planet here
that's three times the mass of this guy
and then this one has a half of m1 and
I've written this up there already and
the center of mass when we want to
determine its coordinate it is a
coordinate that depends on this
coordinate system and this origin here
then we need to have the total mass of
the system because it's a mass weighted
coordinate and so the total mass is
going to be four point five and one and
if we want to calculate this this
position function of the center of mass
or C M that is the mass wait here and
then we need the sum of all our masses
times our distances we are going to sum
here over j from 1 to n and what that
means is we need to now write out the
sum for our three planets and we need to
give this radius here so the r1 would be
going from here to here or two who goes
from here there and our three from here
to here we need to write them out in the
I hat direction and in the J hat
direction let's add that here and then
sum it all up and calculate R so let's
write this out we have m1 and we're
going to have 35 and 1035 I had plus 10
J hat plus m-2 that's going to be five
and twenty five and twenty and then M
three we have forty and thirty and what
we can do oh and of course that has to
be divided by my system yes yeah and
what we can do is we can concentrate
first on the X component and then on the
y component yeah maybe we'll just
continue here so we're going to have and
we can plug in all the MS will do for
the X component first we're going to
have m1 and then we have 35 I had Plus
here we're going to have half M 2 that
is 3 M 1 5 plus + 3 we have 0.5 M 140
that's in the I hat direction
and we'll have to divide that over our
system yes and then we do the same for
the Y component 10 plus 3
20 plus 0.5 and 1:30 j-hat and again we
have to divide this over our systemness
so this boils down to let me actually
look at the answer first 70 and 85 so
this boils 2m 1 over the system mass and
we have 70 in the I hat plus 85 in the J
hat direction
so the 70 comes from this term the ad
comes from this and I put it back
together and now we need to plug in this
one here and so we will get in the end
that our CM equals M over 4.5 m so the M
goes away and we have a factor of 1 over
4.5 here we'll divide this through and
we're going to have 15 point 5
fifteen point five in the I hat
direction and 18.9 in the J hat
direction
alright so let's see where this fits on
on our graph here so 15 in the I hat is
somewhere here and all 19 is almost 20
so it's gonna be here Oh about there so
this is my R cm and this here is my
center of mass of the system of these
three little planets of course we use
approximate masses here for the planets
but if we look at the real numbers
imagine that this would be Earth and it
has one earth mass and if they are so
Saturn it would have something like 318
Earth masses and if this is Pluto it
would have 0.0025 Earth Mathis earth
Mathis
yeah you will see that Saturn really
holds all the weight and if we were to
do this calculation with these numbers
here then our our SEM would and keeping
this coordinate system in the
arrangement of the planets then it would
go right into if here's the center it
would go right next to the center right
over here because Saturn just weighs so
so so much more than blue and earth
together